[Music]
ursula k leguin's sixth and final earth
sea novel the other win begins with
this interaction between alder a common
village sorcerer with a great knack for
mending
and the former arc mage ged or
sparrowhawk on gaunt and alder has
traveled a very long way to get to get
to get some advice from him about
something and he finds ged engaged in
daily chores maintaining their farm and
he tells them hey you must be tired take
a nap once you wake up we'll we'll chat
in the cool of the evening or the cool
of the morning we'll figure this out and
so alder wakes up from a
refreshing nap without any terrible
dreams he's having quite a few as we're
going to see in just a moment and he
finds ged engaged in watering plants and
goes to help him and they they finish it
all up and then
uh he you know they they talk and
um ged says that uh you know my wife and
my my daughter
are over in havnor with the king
and the truth is i'm tired this evening
not much disposed to weighing heavy
matters you look tired too so a bowl of
soup may be in another glass of wine
some sleep and we'll talk in the morning
and then alder says something that's
prefiguring what's going on all with
pleasure lord but for the sleep that's
what i
fear
gad says you fear to sleep and alder
says dreams
ah you had a good nap there in the grass
i think and alder says the sweetest
sleep i've had since i left roque island
i'm grateful to you for that boone lord
maybe it will return tonight but if not
i struggle with my dream and cry out and
wake and i'm a burden to anyone near me
i'll sleep outside if you permit and
sparrow sparrowhawk says it'll be a
pleasant night
and before midnight awakened by a cry
voices outside he leapt up and went to
the door it was only alder struggling
with nightmare amid sleepy protests from
the henhouse alder shouted in the thick
voice of dream then woke starting up in
panic in distress he begged his host
pardon and said he would sit up a while
under the stars sparrowhawk went back to
bed he was not awakened again by alder
but had a bad dream of his own
and
get himself dreams of the wall of stones
one that he has remembered before then
the next morning he is going to talk to
alder and start to get the real story
from him about what is going on
and they have you know a cup of warm
barley gruel
and then
alder says
um i will try to be brief and god says
man we have all the day before us and i
like a story told from the beginning so
alder told him his story from the
beginning he tells him about his
background being a witch's son
from uh town the isle of the harpers and
then he he you know learns to become a
mender and eventually he meets the woman
who is going to be the love of his life
here's the description
he had become a mender then a sorcerer
with a modest practice and local
reputation for his gift when he was
about 30 he went to the principal city
of the island maoni with a harper who
was playing for a wedding there he would
mend the harper strings as they were
breaking a woman sought him out in their
lodging a young woman not trained as a
witch but she had a gift she said the
same as his and wanted him to teach her
and indeed she had a greater gift than
his
though she knew not a word of the old
speech she could put a smashed jug back
together and meant to frayed out rope
with just the movements of her hands in
a wordless song she sang under her
breath and she had healed broken limbs
of animals and people which alder had
never dared to do and here's a beautiful
description so rather than his teaching
her they put their skills together and
taught each other more than either had
ever known she came back to alini and
lived with alder's mother blackberry who
taught her various useful appearances
lily was her name and lillian alder work
together there and in all the hill towns
nearby as their reputation grew so they
practice a a craft something that gets
at the very realities of material things
and they
learn together and from each other and
through this a closeness develops as
alder says we i came to love her
they fell in love together her hair was
dark with a shining a red gold in it
there was no way he could hide his love
from her and she knew it and returned it
so so far so good what a wonderful story
right two people who fall in love
together
and
make a life that is you know partly
magic and partly
good sense and you know intimacy and all
those things she becomes they're married
they lived in great happiness for a year
and half a second year
alder says nothing was wrong at all
until the time came for the child to be
born but it was late and then very late
the midwives tried to bring on the birth
with herbs and spells
but it was as if the child would not let
her bear it it would not be separated
from her it was would not be born and it
was not born
it took her with it
after a while he said we had great joy
and my sorrow was in that degree
i could bear it you know how it is there
was not much reason to be living i could
see but i could bear it but then
in the winter two months after her death
there was a dream came to me
she was in the dream and this is what
the
key thing is here it's not just grief it
is a
dream that occurs
alder is going to meet her
at the wall of stones we know the wall
of stones from the earth sea stories and
from what ghett is going to say as the
wall that separates the dead from the
living in the dry land alder doesn't
actually know
what this is when it's happening
so
he says i stood on a hillside along the
top of the hill running down the slope
was a wall low like a boundary wall
between sheep pastures she was standing
across the wall from me below it it was
darker there she was calling to me i
heard her voice saying my name and i
went to her
i knew she was dead i knew it in the
dream but i was glad to go i couldn't
see her clear and i went to see her to
be with her and she reached out across
the wall it was no higher than my heart
i had thought she might have the child
with her but she did not she was
reaching out her hands to me so i
reached out to her and we took each
other's hands and ged says you you
touched
and he said i wanted to go to her but i
couldn't cross the wall my legs wouldn't
move i tried to draw her to me and
wanted to come it seemed as if she could
but the wall was there between us we
couldn't get over it
so she leaned across to me and kissed my
mouth and said my name and she said
set me free and now notice they didn't
just touch with their hands they are
able to kiss
they have an embrace
the dead and the living across the wall
that separates them
so he says i thought if i called her by
your true name maybe i could free or
bring her across that wall and i said
come with me mevra but she said that's
not my name har that's not my name
anymore and she let go my hands though i
tried to hold her she cried set me free
hara but she was going down into the
dark
it was dark down that hillside below the
wall i called her name and her use name
and all the deer names i'd had for her
but she went on away and then i woke so
it's a dream in which he can't save her
he can't bring her back and notice that
he talks about using her true name her
use name and all these other names of
intimacy and friendship and affection
and none of it works
so
sparrowhawk says you actually gave me
your name and then he says do you know
what that place is and he he explains to
him
what the wall
means
it's the wall that separates the living
and the dead and then he tells him
something
very interesting
hara you are the first man i ever knew
or heard of among all the great mages in
the lore of rock or palm or the enlars
whoever touched whoever kissed his love
across the wall and he says what what
was it like and alder says i don't know
i can't tell you you know i don't
remember the physical sensations
in that case but she's she's you know
asking him set me free right and so
that's part of what he
carries
with uh him and he says i took it for a
dream it troubled me but i i cherished
it
it was like a harrow on my heart's
ground to think of it a hero is a a
trench right dug into it scarred into
his heart and yet i held to that pain
held it close to me i wanted it i hoped
to dream again
it's great love that is motivating
this
between them right
so
this is something quite quite important
then nine days later he has another
dream i was in the same place but high
up on the hill i saw the wall below me
across the slope so he sees it he's like
oh maybe i can see her again so he
rushes down
and she's not there instead there is
somebody else who
he knows his old teacher
ganet
who
was in fact you know a mage who named
him he had been dead these five years
and what was he doing
he kept crying and straining at a stone
with his fingers at first um
alder thinks that the guy is trying to
fix the wall as it turns out no he's
actually trying to pull a stone
out of the wall to start to undo
this wall of stones and he says help me
set me free and the idea is maybe if the
wall gets broken that's how they would
be
set free
and
you know that's not a great dream right
there he's not seeing his wife and then
something else happens
he stood up and reached across the wall
as she had done and caught my hand but
his hand burned with fire with cold i
don't know but the touch of it burned me
so i pulled away and the pain and fear
of it woke me from the dream he held out
his hand as he spoke showing a darkness
on the back and palm like an old bruise
and he says i've learned not to let them
touch me the touch of the dead
hurts him except for of course the touch
of his his love right
who he never gets to see again
in these dreams it's many many other
dead coming to him
and calling him by his name
says the next night when he slept again
he found himself on that hill he went
down to it hoping to find his wife there
instead it's a crowd of shadowy people
some clear some dim some he seemed to
know others he did not know all of them
reached out their hands to him as he
approached and called them by his name
hara let us come with you hara
set us free and he says it's a terrible
thing to hear one's true name called by
strangers and it's a terrible thing to
be called by the dead he tries to turn
and go back up the hill but he finds
himself unable to do so and he wakes up
from the dream and then the next night
it's the same thing over and over and
over again the hillside the wall of
stones the dead asking to be set free
some of them picking away
at the wall of stones so
what to do in such a case the harper who
he works for can tell that there's
something wrong
and he sends them to a mage barrel a
wizard at aya
another one of the important islands
actually one of the first to come out of
the sea
and
beryl says oh this is actually a matter
for those why's of rock
and he spends a good bit of time there
at the island of rock with the the
masters trying to figure out what to do
with him and then finally the patterner
sends him on to
to get
and ged can't do that much for him
other than hear the story and
do some speculations and also have him
fix a picture
but then he uh
he has uh
alder come with him and introduces him
to moss who
now is quite old as a witch
and uh
they decide to get him a
kitten
um
so
uh first they're gonna look for a puppy
and it turns out the puppies are all
gone
um and then uh he says oh you know what
about
the kittens
and heather says oh the kittens little
gray had four old black he killed one
before we could stop him but there's
still two or three somewhere around here
she picks up a kitten and throws him at
ged and it says it instantly bit him
there there there now he told it calm
down a timely rumbling growl emerged
from it and tried to bite him again moss
gestured he set the little creature down
in her lap she stroked it with her slow
heavy hand it flattened out at one
stretch looked up at her and ged says
may i borrow it for a while and she
gives it to him and he says master alder
here is having troublesome dreams i
thought maybe having an animal with him
nights might help to ease the trouble
and so
moss gives the kitten to alder it
scrambled up his arm and clung to his
neck under his hair which he wore
loosely gathered at the nape and as they
walked back to the old mage's house the
kitten tucked inside alder's shirt
and ged then explains a little bit about
the wall of stones but he also talks
about why why get him a kitten
he says last night i was thinking about
how witches often have a companion of
familiar my aunt had an old dog that
never barked she called him go before
the arc mage in emerley when i first
came to roque island had a raven that
went with him everywhere i thought about
a young woman i knew who wore a little
dragon lizards a hereki for her bracelet
and so i thought at last of my otak
then i thought if what alder needs is to
keep him on this side of the wall is the
warmth of a touch
why not an animal since they see life
not death maybe a dog or cat is as good
as a master of rogue
and then we find out so it proved
the kitten evidently happy to be away
from the household of dogs and tomcats
and roosters and the unpredictable
heather tried to show that it was a
reliable and diligent cat patrolling the
house for mice riding on alder shoulder
under his hair when permitted and
settling right down to sleep purring
under his chin as soon as he lay down
alder slept all night without any dream
he remembered and woke to find the
kitten sitting on his chest washing its
ears with an air of quiet virtue and
this is going to keep him from having
those terrible dreams as it's going to
turn out the kitten will go with him
along quite a long ways he will in fact
name it tug
and
it will keep him from having these these
dreams
so
this is where the book essentially
begins with a problem
and something that sparrowhawk or ged
realizes is some kind of
important
change in the works
you